(mouse clicking)
(electronic jingle)
- Program Director the UCSF Family
and Community Medicine Residency.
She is also faculty in UCSF's
Addiction Medicine Fellowship
and helped to write
the national guidelines
in the management of opioid use disorder
in pregnant and parenting
women and their children.
And Diana is gonna talk to us today
about the pediatric effects
of parental substance use.
We're gonna take a couple
minutes for questions
after her talk because she's gotta go
pick up a child after that.
So Diane, thank you for being here.
- Thank you.
And thank you to the conference schedulers
for being so accommodating.
So yeah, this is, I think,
gonna be a little bit of a different talk.
I spend most of my time
thinking about addiction
and how we address it both as clinicians
and as a society.
So you're gonna see a lot of that come out
in what I'm talking about.
I'm gonna be focusing on the impact
of parental substance use
on pediatric development,
but I can't help but
include some commentary
on our society and the way we
treat people with addictions.
So that's gonna be all mixed in.
In fact, okay, I've got
nothing to disclose.
Nobody's paying me
anything besides my salary.
So today, we're going to explore the fetal
and pediatric impact of
intrauterine drug exposure.
We're also gonna explore
the pediatric impact
of parental substance use.
And I'm finding more and
more as I think about this,
I'm finding it really
useful to separate those
as two related but separate issues
that actually require different
kinds of interventions.
And then we're gonna talk about strategies
for mitigating the impact
of parental substance use
including intrauterine exposure.
I want to start.
Here's my commentary to begin with.
So people with substance use disorder
have a disease that responds to treatment.
This is a graph of relapse rates
for other chronic diseases.
This is from an old study
where they looked at people
who had a chronic disease
that was well controlled,
and they watched them for a year
and watched what percent of them
lose control at some point in that year.
And it's not that different
for substance use disorder
as it is for some of these
other chronic diseases.
The real difference
is that when your hypertension
goes out of control,
it's like you have a troubling
visit with your doctor
and they increase your meds,
and you're back to okay.
Whereas with substance use
disorder when you relapse,
it can be that your whole
life falls apart, right?
So it's much more of a dramatic relapse,
but the nature of the
disease is not that different
from other chronic diseases.
I could talk with you
about that for an hour,
but that's all I'm gonna say about that.
What's been nice as the
opioid crisis has unfolded
is that the public health conversation
really has acknowledged
that with the opioid crisis.
There's been a relatively sympathetic
response to the opioid crisis
that is in part because of the groundwork
that's been laid by addiction medicine
where we have a lot better understanding
of the neurologic antecedents to addiction
and the neurologic and kind of
organic nature of addiction.
And it's partly because of racism, right?
The opioid epidemic is primarily
throughout the country a white epidemic,
and so the public health response
and the public response in general
has been a more sympathetic response
than our response to other
drug crises in the past.
And I think it's very important for us
to be aware of that so
what we can do better
the next time there's a drug crisis
that may not be predominantly white.
I will say in California actually,
the opioid crisis is
much more multiracial.
So it's a little bit
different here in California,
but that is an important part
of what's happening nationwide.
Now, if you look,
these are some typical
images from public health
and sort of laypress
about the opioid crisis
and you can see how sympathetic they are.
Like there's somebody
who's trapped by the pills
and the opioid epidemic hits home.
These are the images you see
if you Google addicted mother.
So the images suddenly become
totally unsympathetic, right?
The image over on your left,
the main character is the fetus.
The second character is the needle
and the mother is like some
kind of drug delivery mechanism.
And we see that,
I see it so intensely in the
conversations we're having
around pregnant people using drugs.
In this one up here, the baby's
being born out of a syringe
as if there's like no
parent at all involved
and all that this baby is made out of
is its exposure to heroin.
And so I want to just highlight that
because this is a really emotional issue.
And it's an issue where we get
extremely protective of the fetus,
which is, you know, a reasonable thing.
And also, I find it increasingly important
to just recall that there's a mother too.
There's a mother who has
problems and needs help too.
And when we fall into kind
of demonizing the mother
and sort of reifying the fetus
when we talk about this issue,
we forget the reality that
they're actually connected
and they kind of need each
other and care about each other.
And when I work with pregnant women
who have substance use disorder,
the question they ask me always
when we're discussing treatment options
is well, what's best for the baby?
What can I do to make sure my
baby doesn't have withdrawal?
Like they want healthy babies
and babies want moms, right?
Who are present, and
are healthy, and around.
And so this tendency we have
to separate the needs of these two beings
as though they're not intimately
reliant on each other,
I think it's an inaccurate understanding
of what's happening.
In these states in the country,
pregnancy is considered child abuse
which you can imagine
impacts people's desire
to show up for prenatal care
or tell us they need help.
You can also imagine that
it impacts the conversation
about abortion access
when you start labeling
fetuses as children.
And so I've already said this,
but the thing that I want us
to remember over and over again
is that if we want to help these children,
and these fetuses, and these babies,
we really need to help the whole family
because what's good for the baby
is usually the same thing as
what's good for the family.
Okay.
So I mentioned earlier
that I'm interested in separating out
the impact of intrauterine exposure
and the impact of parental
use during childhood.
And so I've put up just
kind of some theoretical,
theoretically we might imagine that
parental use could lead to
behavioral issues in the child
to an increased risk of substance
use later for the child,
to cognitive issues, ADHD.
And then intrauterine exposure
might also lead to all of those things,
and also we'd be looking specifically for
congenital anomalies,
intrauterine fetal demise,
growth restriction, preterm birth.
So we're gonna look at
some of the literature on specific drugs
and see what we actually
know about the impact
of intrauterine exposure and parental use.
So anyone know which
of the following drugs
is the most likely to cause fetal harm.
Raise your hand if it's heroin.
(laughing) Okay, people wanted to.
If it's methamphetamine?
Okay.
If it's alcohol?
I mean, yeah, right?
Right, right, right.
And second is probably tobacco actually.
So you know this 'cause
you know about FASD
better than most audiences,
but we spend so much time
getting really worked up here,
and like this has been going on forever
and we've not gotten a handle on it.
So good job knowing that.
So we're gonna go through
the different drugs
and drug classes that we
know enough to talk about.
And I'm gonna start with opioids
'cause that's where all the press is.
So I'm gonna talk just really
quickly about maternal risks
and then fetal, pediatric,
and neonatal risks.
So maternal risk.
If you're injecting,
you have a whole bunch
of infectious risks.
Without injection, you still actually
have higher rates of STI,
higher rates of violence,
withdrawal, and for some reason,
this slide doesn't have overdose and death
which should be on here.
And really, it's the withdrawal,
and the overdose, and death
that are attributable to the opioids.
The rest are attributable to things
that come with opioid use disorder.
Now, for the fetus, the newborn,
and the child as the child grows,
there is increased risk of preterm birth
among children born to women
with opioid use disorder.
There's increased risk
of growth restriction
and low birth weight.
There's increased risk of
exposure to infections,
exposure to other drugs.
Now, all of these are not
actually caused by the opioid
and the reason I can say that
is that when you treat opioid use disorder
with buprenorphine, which is an opioid
that we give for the treatment
of opioid use disorder.
When a pregnant person takes
that throughout pregnancy,
their risk of preterm birth
and of growth restriction
normalizes, right?
So we don't think it's the opioid itself
that's causing the problem.
We think it's a bunch of other things
that are associated with opioid use,
and I've got a slide on
that in just a minute.
There's a little.
This should be like half an asterisk here
'cause maybe it's caused by the opioid.
Some mixed evidence about
cognitive and behavioral issues,
and I'll show you some studies.
Maybe caused by the opioid.
More likely, in my opinion,
caused by the environment after birth.
And then of course,
neonatal opioid withdrawal
syndrome or NOWS
occurs in 50 to 80% of exposed infants.
Has not been associated,
and we have looked,
it has not been associated
with developmental issues
further down the line,
but is a difficult phase
for the neonate to have to go through
and for the family actually
to have to go through.
So here's that image I was promising you.
This was a paper that
was published last year
where they explored, and I
know this print is small,
the many factors other
than opioid exposure
that are impacting a fetus
of a mom with opioid use disorder.
So maybe poorer prenatal care,
maybe decreased access to healthcare,
maybe neighborhood
violence, maybe maternal.
The mothers have higher rates
of adverse childhood events.
They have trauma histories.
They may have emotional dysregulation.
They may have nutrition access issues.
So there's all these things
that I'm not gonna read
through all of them
that are impacting the fetus
during birth, during pregnancy.
And one of the things we want to target
when we're treating these parents
is all of this stuff, right?
So it may be okay,
and this is what we've seen
specifically with buprenorphine.
We can replace the opioid
with another opioid.
If that stabilizes all of this,
the fetus seems to do okay.
Alright.
Here's a painful, painful slide.
So an example.
I'm gonna show you two studies
looking at the impact of
opioids on development.
So this is a study where
they looked at 72 children
and they tested them at one, two, three,
four and a half, and
eight and a half years.
These were children of
mothers who used opioids
and other substances.
It is very difficult to find
people who only use opioids
and don't smoke, or drink,
or occasionally use other substances,
so these are poorly controlled studies.
This study actually only,
in terms of the environment,
controlled for foster
placement and heroin use
as opposed to prescription use.
And what they found was
that in the female children,
they found a statistically
significant difference
in cognitive scores at
eight and a half years
but not prior to that,
which I think suggests
that it was more of an environmental issue
than an intrauterine exposure issue.
In the boys, interestingly,
they found p values
of statistical significance throughout
which, it's really hard to
interpret what that means.
Does that mean that boys
are more vulnerable to opioid exposure?
Is it that they're more
vulnerable to the stressors
like elevated cortisol
levels intrauterine?
Are they more vulnerable to withdrawal?
We don't know, but that is one finding.
More recently, there was this study
where they followed a group of women
who had been treated with buprenorphine
and methadone during their pregnancy
meaning there was
continued opioid exposure,
but a resolution of those other stressors.
And they measured a whole bunch
of things in these children
including going into their homes
and looking for acceptance in parenting,
organization in the home,
learning materials that were available,
and then all of these indicators
of various aspects of development.
And what they found was
that up to 36 months,
children follow a path
of normal development.
Growth parameters suggest
that prenatal opioid exposure
does not affect normal
physical development
and conclusions are similar
in terms of cognitive, language,
sensory, and temperament.
So again, we think
that if we can normalize
those social exposures,
we can actually resolve
most of what we see in
some of the studies.
Cocaine and methamphetamine use.
So maternal risks are many.
So in addition to the sort of
infective risks of injection,
there are all kinds of
cardiovascular risks
and psychosis and formication.
Do people know what formication is?
It's where you feel like
there are bugs crawling in your skin
and so there's that
picking that goes with it.
The psychosis associated
with methamphetamine use
specifically can last up to
a year after stopping use.
It's really profound.
For a fetus, a neonate, and a child,
we see explicit impact on the placenta
from the repeated hypertension
that comes with exposure to
cocaine and methamphetamine.
So we see placental insufficiency
which means less blood flow to the fetus
which means growth restriction,
reduced birth weight.
We have higher risk of those.
We have higher risk of
placental abruption.
Higher risk of intrauterine fetal demise.
And maybe in terms of development,
maybe some attentional issues.
I'll show you a little bit
about what we know there.
But I want to remind us,
and I alluded to this at the beginning,
that back when, what was
it, the '80s and '90s
when we were seeing increasing
rates of crack cocaine use,
the media went wild on
this notion of crack babies
and absolutely demonized
mothers about their use.
And I use this, again, to
highlight the racial differences
between what we're doing
now and what we did then,
but also to remind us
like we're leaning in that
direction a little bit right now
when we talk about pregnant women
using opioids in the press.
I think it's really important for us
to learn from our history
because here's a systematic
review that came out in 2010,
so after all of that had died down.
The potentially stigmatizing label
of the so-called crack baby
preceded the evidence now accumulating
from well-designed
prospective investigations
that have revealed less severe sequelae
than originally anticipated.
Prenatal cocaine exposure
appears to be associated with
statistically significant
but subtle decrements in neurobehavioural,
cognitive, and language functions,
especially when viewed in the
contexts of other exposures
and the caregiving environment.
Okay.
So basically the same thing
I've been saying about opioids.
There may be some subtle decrements,
but they may be either moderated by
or caused by the environment.
Here's a study where they took adolescents
who had had over 99 days of
in utero cocaine exposure
and they measured all these tests.
And you can see that
they're pretty similar.
There may be a few places
where there's some subtly lower scores
among the adolescents who were
exposed to cocaine in utero,
but it's quite subtle actually.
And the kind of thing that
could probably be mediated
by support in the home.
So tobacco.
So we know the maternal risks
for tobacco use are many.
For the newborn and the fetus,
what we see is again
placental insufficiency
from the vasoconstriction
caused by nicotine,
intrauterine growth restriction
for the same reason,
again, an increased risk
of placental abruption,
again, an increased risk of preterm birth.
For newborns, there's an increased risk
of sudden infant death syndrome
if parents are smoking
cigarettes in the home.
We don't know the mechanism
of that, but it's real.
We also see facial clefts,
and we see some evidence
of maybe some ADHD,
and increased rates of
substance use in adolescence.
Again, are these two from
the home environment?
We don't know.
Cannabis.
This is an area of great
interest and debate right now
and there's very little evidence
to work with as we argue.
So parental risks.
In adolescence, there does
appear to be an increased risk
of developing psychosis and depression
among people who use
cannabis in adolescence.
That's a strong correlation.
We also know that there's an association
with decreased school performance,
reduced cognitive performance.
So in general, those of us in
the addiction medicine world
who tend to be like legalize everything
or at least decriminalize everything,
we still get nervous about
cannabis use in adolescence.
That's something we try to prevent.
In adulthood, there do
seem to be minimal risks.
There is a risk of developing
cannabis use disorder.
The research suggests that the rate
of developing cannabis
use disorder is about 10%
which is higher than
probably most people think.
So that's the main risk of
cannabis use for the mother.
For the fetus, really as I said,
scant literature, lots of debate,
maybe increased risk of memory
issues, attentional issues.
Quality of data is very poor.
And that's all I have to say
about that unfortunately.
We talk more in the questions
if people have specific questions.
Alcohol, again, you
probably have a good sense
of maternal risk of alcohol use.
Pediatric risks, you
also have a good sense of
in this audience.
That's clear, right?
So really, FASD is the thing
we're most worried about
with intrauterine exposure to alcohol.
And you probably know the
literature on FASD as well as I do
but you know that we haven't
identified a safe level of use.
And what we do know
is that there seems to be a dose response
so the more somebody drinks,
the more likely they are to develop FASD,
but we have not been able to say
that below a certain threshold,
you don't have an elevated risk.
And that's why the current recommendation
is not to drink during pregnancy.
So this is a table that
basically summarizes
most of what I just said.
The things, yeah.
This is most of what I just said.
And what you'll notice
is that not surprisingly,
it's really nicotine and alcohol
that seem to have the
greatest known impact anyway.
And that we have a lot of questions about
whether the impacts on development
are environmental or organic.
Okay.
So how do we support children
whose parents use substances?
And there are three things
that I would recommend.
One is that we treat
parental substance use
and that we think of it not
just as maternal substance use
but parental substance use
'cause it's really whoever is in the house
with childcare responsibilities
that is impacting that
child's development.
We enhance parenting and attachment.
I'm gonna talk with you a
little bit in a few minutes
about what we know about parenting
among people who use substances
and how that impacts attachment.
And then that we work societally
and also individually to
enhance the home school
and after school
environment for these kids.
There's something else I was gonna say.
I know.
So I will tell you one
of the recommendations
of the Substance Abuse
and Mental Health Services
Administration around this
is specifically,
the place they've looked at
the data the most closely
and made recommendations
is around children who are
exposed to opioids in utero.
Their recommendation is that we screen
according to the regular well child
screening recommendations for development.
So they're not recommending
additional developmental screening
and that we respond as we would
with any other developmental
issue on our screening.
Okay, so treating parental substance use.
There are many, many, many options
for treating parental substance use.
There are lots of places you can go.
You can go to residential
treatment, outpatient treatment.
You can come to a clinic
and get medication
straight just from a clinic
which can be quite effective,
particularly for opioid use disorder.
You can go to things
like 12 Steps programs,
peer support programs.
Smart Recovery is like a version of AA
that doesn't require you to
submit to a higher power.
So there are a lot of options
for peer support actually.
You can hospitalize people.
You can put people in
dual diagnosis programs
that are specific to managing
both psychiatric conditions
and substance use.
And in any of these settings,
you can provide people with evidence based
and effective medications.
And we have medications
for all of the drugs
that I have put up here.
We have good meds for alcohol.
We have good meds for tobacco.
We have great meds for opioids.
And we have like emerging meds
for methamphetamine use disorder
that we can use these days.
So we can help parents
and we don't need to just write them off.
Parenting and attachment
is more complicated,
but just as critical.
So there are a bunch of studies
looking at parenting and attachment style
among parents who use substances.
We have found that
there's an increased level
of disorganized attachment
among children who have
parents who use substances.
Disorganized attachment
is caused by parental
inconsistency, right?
Parents inconsistently being available
to help you with your
emotionally stressful situations
leads to this disorganized
attachment style.
The kids are less likely to see contact
with their parents when they're stressed.
They're more avoidant
when they're stressed
so they'll like withdraw into themselves
instead of comforting with the parent
which is considered kind of a
healthy attachment approach.
And that those differences
are to some degree
mediated or predicted
by how much the mother
before having the baby
thought she was gonna have a
hard time caring for the baby.
So that maternal anxiety or instinct
does predict how it's gonna
go after the baby's born.
So this is one of the places
we can start to intervene
and work with people
while they're pregnant.
Other studies looking
at the parenting style
have shown that parents who use substances
don't have a different
philosophy of parenting.
Their beliefs about parenting
are actually similar to people
who don't use substances,
but their behaviors are
substantially different, okay?
So they tend to have a less
quote adaptive parenting style.
They tend to be more critical,
less kind of patient
with the errors that their children make.
There tends to be more negativity,
more threatening
and negative reinforcement
in the parenting style.
The quality of the relationship
between the parent and the child
is strongly mediated by
maternal depression and stress.
And so again, this is a clear place
for us to intervene in these families.
We see less maternal structuring.
So maternal structuring is when the mom
sort of sets the rules
and says here's what time we go to bed,
here's when we brush our teeth,
here's what we're gonna do today.
Instead, there's a little bit more
of like the day is flowing
and I'm just trying to get through it.
As a mother, I know both
states well. (laughing)
Alright, we all struggle.
Some have more to struggle with.
There's a higher probability
that they will have multiple other people
caring for their children periodically.
And again, just to what I just said,
some of us have more to struggle with.
This is not because they don't want
to parent in the same way that
many of us want to parent.
There are just so many other stressors,
and needs, and things
they have to take care of
that make it quite difficult.
So this isn't about demonizing
people for doing it wrong.
This is really about just characterizing
how these things get in the way
of the kind of parenting that
really supports these kids.
This is another really intervenable one.
So mothers with substance use disorder
tend to be less clear
about what cues their
kids are giving them.
So knowing oh, this
means my baby's hungry.
This means my baby's tired.
Now, I'm gonna respond to
that cue appropriately.
That doesn't come as naturally.
Often, I think, because they didn't get
that modeling necessarily
themselves, right?
So specifically teaching
people about cues,
how to notice them, how to address them,
it's a useful intervention that we can do
in the first few days of life actually.
So interventions.
So integrating parenting
classes during pregnancy,
integrating it into substance
use treatment, very helpful.
Breastfeeding is a really
helpful intervention actually.
So for babies who've been
exposed to opioids in utero,
we strongly recommend
breastfeeding actually.
It reduces the risk of neonatal
opioid withdrawal syndrome
not because of the opioids
going into the breast milk
to the baby.
There are very minimal
opioids that make it through.
But we think it's actually the holding,
and the skin to skin, and the suckling,
and the eye contact,
and all the things that go with nursing.
So we really want to
support that kind of bonding
and that opportunity to bond
when it's possible to do so.
Teaching infant cues, as I mentioned.
And then parenting class is the focus on
specifically attachment,
and how to build healthy
attachment and consistency,
which is part of building
healthy attachment.
Support groups with a parenting focus.
And there are a lot of evidence
based curricula available
for helping parents
really support children
after drug exposure in utero.
So I listed some of them here.
And then the last thing
of the three that I said.
So treating parental substance use,
assisting with parenting and attachment,
and providing an enriched
environment, right?
So universal pre-school,
Head Start programs.
Filling the home with books.
These kinds of interventions.
And supporting the parents
so that they can really create
a nourishing environment in the home,
I think is one of the most
powerful interventions we can do.
So in summary, parental substance use
is harmful to the whole
family including the child.
Intrauterine exposure can be harmful
and post-partum exposure,
the home environment
can either mitigate or
amplify whatever happened
in the intrauterine environment.
And by treating substance
use disorder in pregnancy,
providing parenting support,
and enriching the home
and school environment,
we can help children and
their families thrive.
Thank you.
(audience applauding)